ومن ولايه شارلي اورفا قال الرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان انه تم ايقاف اعمال البحث
والانقاذ في الولايه اعتبارا من الخميس
وبدات عمليه رفع الانقاض وخلال جولته في
المناطق المتضرره اضاف اردوغان ان البلاد
ستخرج من الكارثه كما خرجت من كوارث سابقه
شاهدنا اثارا مدمره لهذا الزلزال
وفيات وضحايا كثيره في محافظات عشق من
المحافظات التركيه والى الان
21,848 مواطن فقد حياته في هذه الزلازل
واربعه مواطنا
نجوا من هذا الزلزال
هذا وكان رئيس تركي رجب طيب اردوغان قد
ذكر في وقت سابق اثناء تفقده الاوضاع في
مدينه ديار بكر ان عدد المتضررين بسبب
الزلزال
ووعد اردوغان الشعب التركي بانجاز عمليه
اعاده الاعمار في غضون عام واحد فقط
بثلاثه اضعاف من اي من الزلازل التي حدثت
في التاريخ المسجل لتركيا المتخصص وانا
متفقون على تسميتهما بكارثه القرن هذان
الزلزالان اثر على مساحه تقارب 1000 كم
مربع لكن ندى ماراهما تركز على مساحه 500
كم مربع بشكل خاص هذا زلزالان هذا ما مدنا
تؤوي ثلاثه عشر مليون ونصف مليون مواطن
كما ان الهزات الارتداديه اثرت على مدن
اقترب عدد سكانها من 20 مليون نسمه
النتائج المدمره للزلزال الاول كانت كبيره
لانه باغه المواطنين في وقت الفجر اما
الثاني فكانت نتائجه اقل لانه اتى وقت
الظهيره
هذا وقالت اداره الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه
ان الهزات الارتداديه لا تزال مستمره
وشدتها تتراوح ما بين اربع وخمس درجات على
مقياس ريختر سجلت اليوم هزه ارتداديه بقوه
اربع درجات على مقياس ريختر في كهرمان
مراش مركز الزلزال وفقا للسلطات فان اكثر
من الفيها ارتداديه سجلت منذ وقوع الزلزال
فجر الاثنين الماضي